Ukraine's President Vladimir zielinski
has hailed his troops fighting in back
moot Keys Ground Forces say troops are
advancing on the eastern city controlled
by Russia zelenski said they have
defended their positions and continue to
move forward
I'm grateful to every one of our
soldiers all our Defenders who during
this day have provided the news we have
been waiting for we see how Russia
reacts hysterically to every step we
take there all positions we have taken
the enemy knows that Ukraine will win
they see it they feel it thanks to your
strikes Warriors especially in the
danesque region I want to particularly
highlight the fifth separate assault
Brigade and the 57th separate motorized
infantry Brigade which skillfully
decisively and effectively defended our
positions destroyed the occupiers and
most importantly move forward
comments come on a day of claim and
counterclaim in what could be the start
of Ukraine's long-awaited
counter-offensive Charles Stratford has
the latest from Keith
the Russian army says this video shows
Ukrainian military vehicles being forced
to withdraw after a failed attempts to
push into russian-occupied territory in
the southern Donetsk region of eastern
Ukraine
on June the 4th the enemy launched an
unsuccessful attempt at a large-scale
offensive in the South donett's
Direction six mechanized and two tank
battalions of the enemy were activated
their goal was to break through our
defenses in the most vulnerable in their
opinion sectors of the front the enemy
did not achieve its tasks it had no
successes
the statement which is difficult to
independently verify comes a few days
after Ukraine's President Vladimir
zielinski said his armed forces were now
ready for a long-awaited Ukrainian
counter-offensive his foreign minister
implied the same we received enough
weapons to begin the counter-offensive
but I will say again my answer is it's
always the same to this
I will say that we received enough of
weapons
after we win
because until
we haven't won
there is there will be Never Enough of
weapons
the Ukrainian military says this video
shows Russian positions coming under
heavy fire to the south of the town of
bahut which Russia claimed full control
of last month hours later the leader of
the Russian mercenary group Wagner
released an audio message saying
Ukrainian forces were making small gains
in the village of berkiefka north of the
town yet again blamed Russian defense
minister Sergey shoigu and chief of
general staff Valeri kerosimov
part of berkivka has already been lost
the troops are quietly running away what
a disgrace shoigu gerasimov I urge you
go to the front line pick up a gun and
make the troops stand up and move
forward come on you can do it and if not
you will die Heroes
Ukrainian military in recent days has
launched what can be described as a
campaign of Silence
it released this video aimed at the
public the media and Ukrainian soldiers
appealing for silence on the
counter-offensive in order to preserve
some element of surprise
and with the claim and counter claims
there is increasing evidence of an
intensification of fighting at various
locations along the front line whether
this represents the beginning of the
long-awaited Ukrainian counter-offensive
and efforts by Ukrainian forces to find
weak spots in Russian defense or indeed
these are small probing attacks ahead of
a larger full-scale operation
well that will become clear in the
coming days Charles Strafford Al Jazeera
Kiev
well Frank ledwig is from the University
of Portsmouth he says it's not clear if
Ukraine's counter-offensive can succeed
the general rule and there are huge
exceptions to this Gulf War for example
or the Iraq Wars uh the the general rule
is you need a three to one numerical
preponderance and certainly the
ukrainians do not have that
what they do have and can assemble is
local superiority and equipment and the
human element which is morale and
Leadership which certainly will be
greater and training of course certainly
will be far more developed in the
Ukrainian side than the Russian
the difficulty is of course the length
of the lines
and uh and and the degree to which they
can penetrate into Russian lines before
coming under the Russian air umbrella
which means that they'll be vulnerable
to Russian air attacks they'll be fully
aware of that so what we can expect I
think over the next few weeks and months
is not one operation but many causes to
reinforce to take counter-attacks from
the Russians making sure that the flanks
are guarded and and sustaining pressure
where it's producing results but this
isn't going to be decisive anytime soon
there'll be setbacks on the Ukraine
inside there'll be successes and we'll
only hear about most of those I suspect
afterwards